[Musique]
2 août 1999
bruxelles deux jeunes guinéens sont
trouvés morts dans le train
d'atterrissage d'un avion de la sabena
il avait 14 et 15 ans il s'appelait
yaguine et fodé et porter sur eux une
lettre un message adressé à nos
dirigeants européens 19 novembre 2014
easing ii' république démocratique du
congo des moustiquaires imprégnées de
pesticides fournis par l'aide étrangère
sont distribués par les gouvernements
aux villageois et quelques semaines plus
tard on se rend compte qu'ils les
utilisent en filets de pêche
ces événements n'ont apparemment rien à
voir l'un avec l'autre
apparemment rien à voir avec nous et
pourtant je suis venu vous parler d'un
enjeu majeur qui se joue pour l'instant
qui nous concerne tous c'est l'avenir du
continent africain alors pourquoi est-ce
que l'avenir du continent africain nous
concerne tous cela fait pourtant
cinquante ans que nos pays développent
des politiques des d'étrangères de
gouvernement à gouvernement
avec notre argent de contribuables cela
fait pourtant 50 ans également que des
ong internationales développe des
programmes des des envois sur le terrain
des techniciens et des experts du
développement qu'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui une partie de la jeunesse
africaine car bien sûr je ne parle pas
des jeunes qui quittent leur pays pour
des raisons de guerre et de dictature
mais une partie de la jeunesse africaine
pense qu'elle n'a pas d'autre choix que
de risquer sa vie pour venir chercher un
allié à un avenir meilleur chez nous
mesdames et messieurs force est de
constater que
l'aide étrangère n'est pas suffisamment
efficace
il y a moyen de la rendre plus efficace
et je suis venu vous en parler mais
d'abord analysons ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et pour ça je voudrais vous
parler des deux piliers sur lesquels une
société se base pour se développer
le premier pilier ce sont les gens je
suis psychologue de formation thérapeute
familiale est systémique et dans mon
parcours professionnel j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de familles beaucoup de
systèmes qui avait chaque fois en eux la
force de surmonter leurs difficultés
j'ai eu la grande chance dans le cadre
du travail de mon mari de partis vivre
cinq ans en afrique du sud et j'ai
travaillé bénévolement au coeur du
township de soweto dans un projet local
défini par des locaux pour des locaux et
là j'ai compris une chose essentielle
qui mieux que peut définir les besoins
dessiner les solutions et les mettre en
place avec des moyens adaptés à leur
contexte
l'autre pilier sur lequel une société se
bat pour se base pour se développer ce
sont les autorités
les premières responsables du cadre de
former un cadre pour les droits de leurs
citoyens et c'est la synergie entre ces
deux piliers qui fait qu'une société se
développe de manière durable et l'idée
que je viens vous apporter aujourd'hui
c'est qu'au fond l'aide étrangère telle
qu'elle est pensé et dessiné empêche ces
synergies vient se substituer à ce qu'il
devrait se passer entre ses deux piliers
je m'explique
d'un côté vous avez ces gouvernements
africains qui sont bien plus intéressés
de savoir quelle va être la hauteur de
la manne budgétaire qui vont recevoir
des pays du nord que de s'intéresser à
leurs propres citoyens
d'un autre côté vous avez
cette société civile créative ingénieuse
mais qui ne croient pas dans ses
institutions et qui donc très
naturellement se tourner vers les
étrangères privées
vous voyez que l'aide étrangère agi de
manière parallèle alors qu'au fond il
faudrait encourager les synergies entre
ces deux piliers du développement
certains auteurs vont jusqu'à dire que
l'aide étrangère et même un frein au
développement les gouvernements écoutent
leurs créanciers internationaux
plutôt que de s'intéresser à leur propre
société civile à ce sujet il existe un
livre très intéressant qui s'appelle
l'aide fatale de dmp samui ou économiste
et ancien consultant à la banque
mondiale qui a fait l'effet d'une bombe
et je dois dire que moi non plus avant
de m'intéresser à ce sujet je ne pouvais
pas imaginer que l'aide étrangère
pouvait faire pire que mieux mais nous
sommes des soyez des citoyens
responsables nous voulons être
conscients de nos actes et en connaître
les impacts et donc si il faut analyser
analysons s'il faut adapter adaptant en
gros ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'aide étrangère augmentent les
ressources disponibles des gouvernements
africains qui donc ne s'intéresse pas à
leur propre société civile il y a
également des pays africains qui
dénoncent le poids et le pouvoir pris
par l'aide étrangère dans leur pays et à
ce sujet je vous encourage à aller voir
sur internet
le discours du président du ghana qui
s'adresse à emmanuel macron en décembre
dernier et vous comprendrez que qui paye
les violons choisi la musique
j'entends déjà certains se dire eh bien
alors s'il faut arrêter l'afrique
arrêtons pas si simple il existe bien
sûr des solutions et je suis venu vous
parler de cette solution de comment
rendre notre aide étrangère plus
efficace
je travaille pour un réseau qui
s'appelle id id est un réseau qui
regroupe 6 130 ong africaines toutes les
personnes qui ont développé leurs
propres projets pour améliorer la
qualité de l'éducation dans leur pays
des personnes qui s'assure que des
actions sont cohérentes et que des
moustiquaires ne termine pas en filets
de pêche
parce qu'au fond c'est de ça que les
gens avaient besoin
le réseau a deux raisons d'être le
premier ce que il crée une communauté
d'intelligence et de praticiens dans
laquelle ils peuvent échanger leurs
idées leurs bonnes pratiques
leur échec leurs résultats l'autre
grande réseau du réseau et c'est
fondamental c'est qu'ensemble
forts de leurs solutions et des réponses
qu'ils ont apportées à des problèmes
locaux ils peuvent faire valoir
ensemble collectivement ses solutions
auprès de leurs autorités
c'est ce que yaguine et fodé les deux
jeunes guinéens dont je vous ai parlé
demandé dans leur message aidez nous à
créer une organisation qui nous
permettent de nous structurer
cela fait dix ans que le réseau idée
fonctionne sur ce modèle et vous serez
probablement sa intéressé de savoir est
ce que ça fonctionne je voudrais vous
donner deux exemples
le premier concerne la lutte contre le
paludisme
vous savez que le paludisme est une
maladie mortelle il tue encore un enfant
toutes les deux minutes
c'est 210 millions de cas de paludisme
dans le monde chaque année et
principalement en afrique et c'est une
maladie qui pèse très lourd sur le pib
des pays concernés
il existe une plante qui s'appelle
l'artemisia annua cette plante est
utilisée par les chinois depuis plus de
2000 ans et c'est une membres de notre
réseau au kenya qui en a fait
l'expérience en premier il y a huit ans
ils ont décidé de l'intégrer dans des
jardins scolaires
d'apprendre aux jeunes à faire pousser
cette plante à la faire sécher et l
apprendre sous forme de tisane en
prévention contre la malaria puisqu'elle
a également des effets préventifs
l'absentéisme des enfants et des
enseignants à diminuer les frais
médicaux en chute et il ya eu un réel
impact spectaculaire sur la santé mais
également sur la qualité d'éducation des
enfants
et là évidemment la force du réseau
opérer et depuis huit ans des
associations membres du réseau développe
en afrique des projets d'artemisia noah
nous sommes en mars 2018 à kigali et id
one dame décide de faire valoir cette
solution naturelle peu coûteuse et
efficace auprès de sa ministre de la
santé
nous sommes trois femmes la ministre de
la santé qui représente ces autorités
nadine ingabiré qui représente idée
rwanda c'est à dire une coalition de 35
organisations de la société civile
rwandaise et moi qui est là pour
représenter le réseau panafricain et
l'expertisé que nous avons acquise en en
matière de lutte contre le paludisme
grâce à cette plante
la ministre de la santé ne connaît pas
la plante elle pose énormément de
questions se rend compte sur internet et
enfin en faisant ses recherches qu'il
existe des centaines de recherches
scientifiques qui prouvent l'efficacité
de la plante et corrobore les résultats
que nous obtenons tout sur le terrain
trois mois plus tard sur twitter
elle annonce que chaque famille
rwandaise recevra son plan d'artemisia
n'est ce pas là un bel exemple d'une
solution locale qui dans un cadre
officiel est multiplié à grande échelle
maintenant je vous emmène une minute au
togo une association membre du réseau a
identifié un problème récurrent dans les
villages les villageois souhaite adopter
les enfants orphelins ou abandonnés pour
éviter qu'il ne migrent vers les
bidonvilles de la capitale
lorenzi locale
velopper en projets générateurs de
revenus et pour ça elle a sollicité une
aide étrangère afin de louer un champ
communautaire pour que ce village j'en
prends en particulier qui cultive le
manioc puissent cultiver le manioc et
vendre les produits dérivés du manioc
sur les marchés la vente des produits
permet de prendre en charge la scolarité
et les besoins quotidiens des enfants
les autorités ont été invités à venir
visiter rendre visite à ce projet et ont
mis à disposition des villages des
champs communautaires plus grand afin
qu'ils augmentent le rendement
ils ont ainsi acquis le statut de
coopérative qui leur donne droit à des
formations dispensées par le
gouvernement togolais une aide étrangère
une association locale qui se basent et
mobilise toute une communauté et des
autorités qui renforce et multiplient
oui notre aide peut être rendues plus
efficaces
non les membres des autorités des
gouvernements africains ne sont pas tous
corrompus
l'afrique est une que le développement
est une question d'attitude bien plus
que d'argent
il est temps que nous investissions dans
le capital humain de l'afrique
je rencontre souvent des donateurs qui
sont tout à fait prêts à financer
l'achat de livres scolaires le la
construction d'une classe ou même le
forage d'un puits mais dès que je leur
parle de salaire ils sont beaucoup plus
frileux
l'africain se serait-il des bénévoles
il est important essentiel d'investir
dans le capital humain de l'afrique
oui l'afrique est capable de bonne
gouvernance un million d'euros c'est la
somme que quatorze associations membres
du réseau se sont vus se sont vu confier
par l'union européenne pour travailler
une thématique qui juste là jusque là
n'avait pas été beaucoup abordé la
protection et la formation des
travailleurs domestiques kpmg pour ne
pas le citer
à l'issue des trois années du projet a
fait un audit externe 99,7 99,7 % des
dépenses ont été correctement attribués
et comme ces quatorze associations
membres avaient intégré des autorités
dans le projet depuis le début du projet
cela a mené vers des changements majeurs
et notamment au niveau du cadre légal
il est temps d'investir dans le capital
humain de l'afrique
j'espère qu'après ces propos l'image que
vous avez de l'afrique qui est sans
doute une image liée à ce que les médias
nous en montre une image pauvres et sans
ressources
eh bien j'espère qu'elle est devenue
maintenant celle avec laquelle je
travaille tous les jours une aile une
afrique vivante une pépinière de talents
les personnes qui seront capables de
développer l'afrique à long terme elles
sont là bas elles sont peut-être
sociologues anthropologues gestionnaire
de projet elles peuvent aussi apprendre
à remplir des fichiers excel pour nous
remettre les justificatifs des dépenses
mais surtout elles ont une connaissance
inégalable du terrain l'aide étrangère
devient efficace lorsqu'elle permet à
des acteurs sociaux locaux de mettre en
place leur projet d'obtenir des
résultats qui joint aux résultats de
leurs collègues nourrissent un plaidoyer
commun pour mener un dialogue
constructif avec leurs autorités afin
qu'ensemble ils dessinent l'afrique de
demain
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]